there's a couple different ways the
first way to do it is basically just to
move this constant to the other side of
the equation by subtracting 10 from both
sides
so we have Y minus 10 equals x squared
plus 2x plus blank
okay so here's we're going to complete
the square now when the leading
coefficient the number in front of the x
squared is a positive 1 it's very easy
to do this completing the square process
and the other two we're going to do one
where there's not a leading coefficient
of 1 and it'll be a little more
challenging I'll show you how that works
but the first thing is you want to look
at this middle coefficient here this
number in front of the X to the left of
the X you want to take half of that
number and square it so half of 2 is 1 1
squared is 1 okay some people write this
as B over 2 the quantity squared because
this is like ax squared plus BX plus C
so you're taking half of B okay and then
squaring it now the thing is is this is
an equation right out of thin air I just
put one on the right side of this equal
sign so to keep this balanced if I add
one here I have to add one to the other
side as well right to keep it balanced
so we have Y minus 9 equals x squared
plus 2x plus 1 now we've set this up to
be a perfect square so when we factor
this this is going to be X plus 1 the
quantity squared some students have a
little bit of challenge with this just
with factoring but I'll give you a
little hint it's always going to be half
of this middle coefficient okay this
number that's right here if this was x
squared minus 2x plus 1 it'll be X minus
1 will be half of that that middle
coefficient and then we're just gonna
bring down the Y minus 9 and then last
step is we're just gonna add 9 to both
sides so we have y equals x plus 1
squared plus 9 now we know what the
vertex is is going to be negative 1 see
the opposite of 1 comma 9 that's our
vertex and you can see our a value is
actually positive 1 so we know our
parabola is opening up like that but you
can check out some my other videos about
graphing given the vertex form but here
we're just writing it into the vertex
form by completing the square so let's
go to example number 2 so now this one's
a little bit more challenging because of
that leading coefficient of 3 what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to subtract 1 from
both sides of the equation okay
just to get the one out of the way there
but then we're going to do with this
three is rationing and a factor out the
three okay like so now what we want to
do is want to take half of this number
in front of the axe half of this middle
coefficient so half of four is two and
then we square that which is four okay
now it just happens to be a coincidence
that you know this is four and that's
four but you take half the middle
coefficient whatever that is you square
that and you put it there
now here's the thing because this four
is in parentheses we actually have to
distribute the 3 times the 4 that's 12
so out of thin air we're putting 12 on
the right side of the equation so to
balance that we have to add 12 to the
left side of the equation right so I
want to keep it balanced so this is y
plus 11 equals three and then now what
we're going to do is we're going to
factor this quantity in the parenthesis
and remember how it factors its factors
as X plus 2 the quantity squared it's
going to be half of that middle
coefficient if this was minus 4x then
this would be minus 2 right and you can
double-check this by foiling it out X
plus 2 times X plus 2 the last step is
we just want to move this 11 over here
to the other side by subtracting 11 from
both sides and there you go that's your
equation you can see your vertex is
going to be at negative 2 comma negative
11 the 3 is actually going to stretch
the graph it's opening up its gonna be a
little bit narrower but this is gonna be
your vertex where the graph changes
direction right or bends